alright man be alright is massive
obviously you know this you're selling
out tours all over the place take me
back to like even two years ago could
you look into the future too now and
know that this was gonna happen no you
actually like you drop I'm from
Australia and obviously like you hear
that having a song that connects in
America and Canada is like me
it's the third like there's been like
three people that have done it like you
know last ten years so it's something
that kind of you grew up hearing that's
sort of impossible
so yeah just blown away everyday at all
this stuff that's happening yeah are you
getting used to it I mean we were just
talking about the fans coming up your
photos and being noticed and yeah it's
it's a thing that a lot of people want
and you certainly when you get into the
entertainment business a part of it
right absolutely yeah but like are you
getting accustomed to it now yeah I
guess it's tough like I mean I I always
just wrote songs not for the idea for it
to be big and to be like and to get
famous and stuff I've always wrote them
from you know just wanting just because
I've really liked it but that is the
byproduct then you start like you start
getting photos of people and you're like
you know you have to be on your playing
doing lots of performances it definitely
takes a while to get accustomed to but I
think I'm easing into it
yeah it's getting a bit easier so what
is it about that song you think that
just struck a chord with so many people
yeah um well you know it's like it's a
weird song as most of the songs that
I've written they're about like put up
like production you build up the chorus
but be Araya
is really about like you know the lyrics
and getting the vocal sounding riot and
the emotion right and for whatever
reason it's like stuck a chord I wish I
knew exactly what it was but I'm glad it
is yeah when you're writing a song do
you ever like do you ever predict the
life for it do you ever think oh man
this is the one that kept looking love
or this is the one that my family knows
is all about me or whatever like do you
predict a life for a song or you just
kind of let go yeah see where it takes
you yeah I'm I guess I'm one of those
people I like start working on something
about this is the best thing ever like
this is so good and then I'll record it
I'll be like you mean I'll ask my
brother and he'll be like nerds not too
good but you know we'd be alright I knew
it was special because I'd play it to
people before I release that I'd play it
and people always come up to me
afterwards be like that song about the
phone like you should release that and
so I knew it was special but I didn't
know it would do do this yeah yeah and
what's been your experience touring I
mean doing North America is it vastly
different from being in Australia
yeah oh it's so different like in
Australia we do like that obviously the
shows a bigger back home yeah you can
kind of hit like six cities and the tour
is done yeah whereas in America and
Canada like there's so many different
places to go to so it's like I guess
it's bigger
we're in buses like a sleeper bus okay
I'll finish the show yeah sleep on a bus
and wake up in a new city yeah so it's
really cool but I brought my whole band
with me from back home and let my
brothers with me and we're just having
the best time ever
so does this feel like like family like
a bunch of friends hanging absolutely
experiencing this together because this
is a huge it is huge and like we're all
pretty boring like none of us I drink
that much like so like there's no like
it's really actually quite boring with
trying to stay fit on the road because
you know it's quite difficult because
the food here is so delicious but like
so it's I mean a more in America like
Canada it's kind of yeah but um yeah
like it is like a family vibe and we're
just loving it having a great time so it
tells about the new album with
determinar March 22nd yeah it's going
much 22nd and it's called a place we
knew yeah and I like I called it that
because I like it when there's like a
sentence or phrase that tells the story
more like an image and for me it's the
idea of like driving past you know he's
like a place where you started with your
ex and you both like maybe two years ago
and like you both moved on but like the
feelings are still like the memories are
there but even though the feelings are
all gone that was kind of the feeling of
I wanted that the songs to get across
they all have that kind of bittersweet
feeling and when I when I saw those
words or came up with them I sort of
combine them I was like that you know
feels like the album but the songs I'm
more proud of them and I've had so much
time to finish them and work on them and
no pressure because I had a lot of the
songs like you know before like some of
them I had three years ago something
much newer so I'm just really proud of
it yeah and I was gonna ask you it's
funny you say there's no pressure a lot
of people you know when they're coming
up with a new album feel that pressure
to replicate a certain success yeah or a
certain sound or maybe break out of
something whatever it is yeah right
every new project means something new to
you yeah did you did you feel that you
had to replicate a certain success or
you because you're kind of on a steady
climb that everything is new
totally um I guess for me like I think
if I just had be alright and I released
that and then I had nothing else like no
other songs and like a record label was
like you need to you know you need the
next song in a month I wouldn't
be able to ride it I just feel like oh
there's so much pressure but because I
had like I wrote be alright four years
ago and I recorded it like four times
and more recently to get it right like
it took me so long to get right so I
knew I had that and I knew I had some of
these other singles I guess from the
album that a ones out called seven
minutes and the next one I kind of had
these songs so before I released be
alright so the pressure was sort of off
but I think I just I've gotten lucky
with timing like if I if it was
different and I and be alright
it was I released it four years ago and
I didn't have anything else I think it'd
be a very different story but by having
time I think i-i've I don't have as much
pressure in there who would you listen
to going up but do you do you make songs
like songs that you loved when you're
going a little bit like um I I'm big fan
of Bruce Springsteen
yeah like massive fan and when I first
like really heard dancing in the dark
he's like one of these bigger songs like
there's a lion in there which is
messages keep getting clearer radios on
and I'm moving around the place and to
me when I when I looked at I like
googled the lyrics I was like wow he's
literally just describing like walking
around a room and I was like well you
can do that
so I do write songs from that sort of I
guess technique like just describing
scenes and that is something that I just
like to listen to so I just started
doing it myself and it feels really
natural to me yeah um I was looking at
your Instagram and it's funny one of the
most recent posts I mean it'd even be
the most recent post yeah is you talking
about people calling you a bad boy oh
that was a voi a bad was a troll yeah
I'm just an idiot on my Instagram like I
just post the dumbest stuff and yeah I
just I've got it I've got it like I've
got to be more serious like this is the
thing as most people think that like
because I'm right these sad songs that
I'm quite like a serious person but my
Instagram is this like so stupid and I
just do the dumbest things as like a bit
of a joke
okay and yeah but I should probably
should probably most people don't people
can't read tone yeah and that's not
always scared of I'm like I'm posting
something like that this a joke to me
but I'm like I'll go and appeal thing
I'm serious but some people do but um
yeah I just I'm just a bit of an idiot
on Instagram do you obviously you have a
way of communicating through your music
and that's the primary thing yeah but
now that you've reached this level I
mean like you just said like only three
or four other people from Austria
have done it yeah do you ever think
about the way people perceive you are
you concerned about what like an image
that may be forming in the head of who
you are um yeah I guess I'm pretty open
I'm like sort of open and talk about
everything that I'm like what I'm
writing about like I'm also sort of I
guess not afraid to sort of be myself
should I mean like so I think sometimes
like being a singer/songwriter you sort
of there's this perception of how you
should be you know I mean like really
kind of Moody and stuff like that but
it's not me like I kind of separate the
two things like I write these songs and
then I like to have a laugh so I've
always has been super open and and I
don't really care like I'm not too
worried about a perceptional or like how
it's appearing because I just feel like
I'm always me so yeah what do you want
to do after this do you know this whole
North American thing is amazing but
what's your next step we're gonna Europe
after this and and then back to
Australia and then back to Europe back
to America and I think the next year is
going to be like just touring and yeah
it's crazy the shows are selling out
like I mean I played Toronto like a year
ago and there was like 100 people in
this little bar it's like half empty in
there so it's cool to come back in like
sell places out and and for a song to be
connecting like this it's just madness
and you've got that fans now those fans
that were there that are now yeah I mean
like yes I was with them since the
beginning yeah yeah yeah they're
original fan totally and yeah the few
fewer than we messaging me like saying
like yeah I'm coming and it's like it's
cool it's really cool right on man yeah
thank you so much great chat yes yes
you